المتحدث باسم سرايا القدس
عليه وعلى اله وصحبه افضل الصلاه واتم
التسليم ثم اما بعد
يا جماهير شعبنا الابي الشجاع المق
داد يا ابناء امتنا العربيه والاسلاميه
ويا كل الاحرار في العالم
نوجه لكم تحيه الشرفاء الاوفياء الصادقين
من وسط لهيب سعر الاحرار فالسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
منذ اللحظه الاولى لغباء الاحتلال
واقدامه على اغتيال ثله مجاهده من ابناء
شعبنا وفي مقدمتهم الاخ القائد الكبير
خليل البهتيني
والاخ القائد الكبير جهاد الغنام ولكن
قائد الكبير طارق عز الدين كانت قياده
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في انعقاد دائم
ومتابعه حديثه لمجريات وتفاصيل الاحداث
والتطورات الميدانيه
وبفضل الله تبارك وتعالى
خالفت المقاومه كل التوقعات الصهيونيه
بطبيعه الرد
وعلى مدار ما يزيد عن 35 ساعه
وقف العدو جبهته الداخليه المهتريه على
اصابع الاقدام
يرتعشون خوفا
ويرتعدون رعبا
يترقبون رد المقاومه الابيه الذي بدا وما
زال في عمليه ثار الاحرار المباركه
برشقات مكثفه بمئات الصواريخ
تجاه عسقلان وسيديرات وبئر السبع وباتيام
وتل ابيب وبيت شامش ورحفوت وما بعدها
الامر الذي دفع بالاحتلال المجرم الى
تكريس كل جهوده لمواصله غبائه وحماقته من
جديد
فذهب الى اغتيال اخر للاخ القائد المجاهد
علي حسن غالي قائد القوه الصاروخيه في
سرايا القدس
ونائبه المشاهد الاخ القائد احمد ابو دقه
ظنا منه ان عمليات الاغتيال ستوقف المسيره
التي لم تنتهي يوما باي عمليه اغتيال كانت
منذ التسعينيات وحتى هذا اليوم ذلك بان
سرايا القدس منظومه كامله متكامله الجندي
فيها قائد يقود المعركه ويحقق الانتصارات
ويلحق الهزيمه بجيش العدو ايها المجرمون
الصهاينه
اننا باغتيال قادتنا ومجاهدينا نزداد عزما
وتصميما على قتالكم والثار منكم
وامام هذه الدماء المباركه
وسيل صواريخنا المؤيده من الله
والكثافه الناريه المركزه اين الامن
والامان الذي وعد به المجرم نار عن
نتنياهو جبهته الداخليه الناقمه غضما عليه
اننا وبكل وضوح نقول لعدونا الصهيوني
الاحمر
ان اصغر رجل في مقاومتنا الباسله
يوقف اليوم بكل بساله وبلا تردد
ملايين المغتصبين الصهاينه ويدفع بهم نحو
الحياه التي لا يطيقونها
كالجرذان في الملاجئ
اننا في سرايا القدس والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
امام هذه الدماء والتضحيات وفي ضوء هذا
الرد المبارك من خلال الاجماع الوطني
الكبير
والالتفاف الشعبي العظيم
وبعمقنا العربي والاسلامي
مصممون على صد العدوان ضمن عمليه ثار
الاحرار البطوليه
ونؤكد من جديد وعبر الميدان
اثباتنا لفشل سياسه الاغتيالات
والتزامنا التام بالوفاء لدماء الشهداء
ورد العدوان وعلى العدو ان يعلم اننا
حاضرون وجاهزون
لتوسيع دائره النار اكثر فاكثر مهما طالت
المعركه ومهما كلفنا ذلك من ثمن وما النصر
الا صبر ساعه وما النصر الا من عند الله
العزيز الجبار
جهادنا مستمر دون تراجع بعون الله تعالى
والله غالب على امره ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته